[Musica]
già ora è il momento di introdurre no
signori siamo sul episodio di hunger
games ragazzi finalmente dopo un sacco
di tempo ori selezionato un sacco di
persone e personaggi comunque generale e
famosi da inserire negli hunger games
oggi vediamo degli hunger games diversi
dal solito da lì dai soliti personaggi
che ho sempre usato perché gli hunger
games che giocherò oggi vedono come
protagonisti li stretto uno sfera e
basta e anna baker distretto 2 maurizio
costanzo e zhang koch che non ho ancora
ben capito che si pronuncia quindi io lo
chiamiamo solo zhang distretto 3 ultimo
e emila car distretto 4 rupaul e lady
gaga o ottimo peace 35 d'occhio è matteo
salvini ma ancora l'avete visto il
prossimo distretto 6 freddi e alberto
angela giustamente distretto 7 o farli
genio sono una costante in tutti i libri
hunger games è miley cyrus 38 some che
sarebbe il mio cane per chi non lo
sapesse era chi male sembra l'accoppiata
vincente dovevo essere io col mio cane
pro scelto miley cyrus distretto 9
lorenzo casadei e lord voldemort che non
è altro che lorenzo casadei quando
invecchia distretto 10 suns e maria de
filippi distretto 11 2 l'ipa e cole
sprouse distretto 12 p ta e katniss
everdeen cominciamo allora usiamo una
traduzione decente fa vj fugge dalla
cornucopia mila call che rompe il naso
di turalei fa per un cestino di pane va
bene katniss prende una manciata di
coltelli da lancio e di lei ormai
abituate ne ha fatti un miliardo di
hunger games anna becker fugge dalla
portata della porno coppia non stavo
sbagliato a dire meno male che lo faccio
spesso youtuber perché se non lo sarebbe
ancora di più un casino spera e basta a
fugge dalla con lui copia san matteo
salvini calls prosa e maurizio costanzo
condividono tutto ciò che hanno raccolto
prima di correre ce lo vedo same con
salvini giorno una ragazza ci siamo lord
voldemort essa anzi si dividono per
cercare
spero e basta costruisci una baracca sam
scopre una grotta il fiuto del mio cane
non mente mai
alberto angela ha la meglio su rupaul
uccidendola alberto hai studiato un
sacco di battaglie ci sarà un motivo
maurizio costanzo fugge da pete ha poi
novo questa spara bono maria de filippi
riceve un accetta da uno sponsor
sconosciuto figura se quelli di mediaset
non le davano la cena ha quindi ultimo
uccide katniss perché si è rifiutata di
uccidere neo rami malek e meno male
freddi uccide matteo salvini per le sue
scorte lorenzo casadei si mimetizza tra
i cespugli vengo quel cappello ti
mimetizzi ben poco zio tre colpi di che
non ne possono essere ascoltati
lontananza rupaul katniss e matteo
salvini sono morti some mai di sario
serrami discutono i giochi e cosa
potrebbe accadere al mattino la vedo
dura discutere col mio cane però lady
gaga chiedere alberto angela alberto
angela di ucciderla vano rifiuta
mantenendo lady gaga viva lorenzo
casadei e ultimo si tengono per mano
anzi hai sbagliato manager è hai
sbagliato rigore sbagliato manager
ultima vista ci sono dei problemi
trasmette teorico subito pari a de
filippi rimane sveglio tutta la notte
c'era il serale tokyo da fuoco da fuoco
alle cose tokyo da fuoco maurizio
costanzo affetta fa vj con una spada
io non ho parole io non ho parole ha
detto detto che d'evitare bono è niente
la via sono morto ma ucciso maurizio
maurizio dai alberto angela ferisce
gravemente lorenzo casadei ma lo mette
fuori dalla sua miseria cosa vuol dire
che vuol dire che l'ha ferito ma poi
l'ha lasciato vivere vabbè lord
voldemort avanza accidentalmente su una
mina mamma mia il signore oscuro ma
manco le mine siamo morbide poi j
lorenzo casadei e lord voldemort
beh certo siamo morti insieme dovrai
visto tuali petto occhio raccontano solo
su se stessi l'un l'altro a quella volta
che ho rapinato la zecca maurizio stan
soffitta e freddi si danno battaglia
maurizio costanzo uccide trionfalmente
entrambi ma maurizio massei un killer
se una macchina da guerra mauri canone
e lontananza vita e freddi sono morti
next tokyo chiude silenziosamente il
collo di ultimo quindi ultime molto
strangolato da tokyo vabbè alberto
angelucci nel sangue con una falce no è
morto il cane va dai la pioggia cina si
riversa sulla rena maria de filippi non
riesce a trovare riparo e muore
maurizio costanzo sopravvivete pareva
sfera e basta rifiuta rifugio di alberto
angela uccidendolo
mamma mia quanti rifiutano rifugi oggi
tokyo ferisce lady gaga e la lascia
sotto la pioggia per morire ma baker
ferisce 2 marzo avanti sono morti quanta
gente morta porta pure d'oliva otto
colpi di cannes mai mort mai morti in
così tanti in un round attenzione giochi
costringe miley cyrus a uccidere sfere
basta un rami decide cdc dei rami quindi
è morto rami rimangono tokyo miley extra
e basta
miley cyrus non è in grado di convincere
tokyo non ucciderla quindi miley muore
per mano di tokyo sfera e basta muore di
fame ha vinto tocchi veramente il
vincitore tokyo dal distretto 5 ha vinto
tokyo gli hunger games l'avrei mai detto
cioè data l'avrei detto perché era uno
delle più combattive wow
tokyo vince gli hunger games sta cosa
non l'avrei mai detto all'inizio però
complimenti tokyo dove i ragazzi
facciamo un altro tentativo perché l'ho
mandata aggiunge sono morto subito porca
vacca e mila clark e lancia pita
nell'addome cielo lancia contro il suo
addome penso sia morto ma vj strangola
maurizio costanzo con una corda equa fa
ridere per un sacco di motivi il primo
mi sono preso la mia vendetta per prima
il secondo come faccio a strangolare
maurizio che non c'è al collo però va
bene l'importante che bisogna ripresa la
vendetta maurizio una 1 1 a 1 vado al
centro tre colpi di cannone pinta
maurizio costanzo e anna baker andiamo
avanti ragazzi che tinse mila lorenzo 2
l'ipa si raccontano storie di fantasmi
per alleggerire l'atmosfera mamma mia
come la alleggerisci bene con le storie
di fantasmi l'atmosfera che basta e
famiglie si stringono attorno al calore
che cosa significa questa cosa non è
quello che pensi rupaul kahn in una
fossa e muore quali pastelli favi cosa
vuol dire steli fa leggeri può dire che
mi sta mettendo un telo mare addosso ma
succede steli fa vigenti
catherine si ferisce gravemente freddi e
lo lascia morire vabbè lorenzo casadei
insegue fa vj pari ma semplicemente
perché mi vuole accompagnare gli eventi
non è perché mi vuole far male credo
spero ultimo lorenzo casadei matteo
salvini se mai li rintracciano e
uccidono lord voldemort qui ci sono
voluti tutti questi per uccidere lord
voldemort chiaro perché il signor
sconciato di york sparsi per l'arena
quindi l'hanno ucciso
zhang spinge suns da una scogliera
durante lo scontro a coltellate quindi
mi sa che è morto anche sandro ricci
cerca di cantare se stesso per dormire
col dire fa vj fa vj quanto grigi
procedere no catrice uccide sangue
mentre sta riposando al mio cane dai
tokio chiede a due anni fa di ucciderla
con riluttanza uccide tokyo quindi
tocchi è morta perché tualità da uccisa
morti lord voldemort suns some alberto
angela e tokyo katniss si mette a
piangere per dormire per piangere per
dormire un'ottima tattica per dormire
complimenti lei muore di fame
no io madama di fama dai ma almeno
almeno con un combattiva dai
amareggiatissimo sonori b ultimo pensa
di vincere ma se non ci fosse stato ma
wood
la smettiamo da un solo colpo di cannone
può essere sentito in lontananza
indovinate di chi era questo colpo di
cannone di quel pirla di fa vj
ovviamente ovviamente maria de filippi
dual impestare basta rintracciano
uccidono lorenzo
vabbè jean du cinema liz harris mentre
sta talmente simile all'ipad e zhang si
danno battaglia duri paolucci ha
trionfalmente entrambi
wow ma cosa vi ferisce stare basta
taglia gravemente l'animale con una
spada sette colpi di cannone incredibile
lorenzo miley la zhang katniss maria de
filippi rami malek tutti i morti sono
rimasti lì matteo salvini fare basta tua
liba è l'ultimo matteo salvini riceve un
esclusivo da uno sponsor sconosciuto
sembra lega sua lancia un coltello nel
petto di ultimo quindi sono rimasti
attualità e matteo salvini signori
dualità avvelena la bevanda di matteo
salvini lo beve e muore quindi vince
assolutamente tua l'ipa che ha vinto gli
hunger games incredibili argomento tokyo
e dualità poi dicono che donne né gli
hunger games non vinco non è vero se ci
fate caso sempre ragazzi vincoli hunger
games come possibile incredibile v con
sempre ragazze ceco è possibile
va bè ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto questi erano gli hunger
games un po di fatti un po mischiate le
scalate c'è un sacco di personaggi nuovi
che voglio utilizzare oltre questi
fatemi sapere se volete altri episodi
sempre un commento usato cosa i due
ragazzi servite più giornalmente vi
piace quali sono le delizie da proveremo
a vincere rispetto a tutti quelli che
tentano di strangolarmi come maurizio e
non ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
da ragazzi
[Musica]